[Music] I
changed jobs because my power-harassing boss called me mentally.
[Music] It's my
workday today. I'm Shirasaki. I'm Shirasaki. I ca
n't read his facial expressions at all. If this person was also a power-harassing boss,
Moses would have compiled the handwritten notes.  Sorry, thank you very much,
but I couldn't help
but blow away my worries.
[Music] My
new boss was so natural.
[Music] I want to
meet my classmates. I wonder how old they are now. That's great.
No one is interested in me.  I only see the manager now. I
can't be lonely.
[Music] A
fun and soothing work comedy with a new boss.
[Music] The
new boss is natural.
TV animation decided to be made.
[Music]
When will Cheers be made?